russell peters how are you doing man
it's been a long time how are you
holding up
roz i feel like i've watched you
transition into this adult that you are
now over the years
i remember when you kind of looked like
you were a little gothy before
you know it was dark and and nine inch
naily
and uh yeah and then i watched you clean
cut and trench it's like a transition
only you've transitioned into this adult
yeah now now i just look tired i i'm
tired as hell
what is your life like right now how
have you been coping what have you been
able to do because
especially for comics you guys have had
to really
just come up with a with a new playbook
during
lockdown right well i mean my my life
went upside down during
lockdown everything changed in my life i
mean
yeah uh from my uh my home life
to where my home was to
you know you had to make all these kinds
of uh sacrifices
you start to realize what was important
what was not what had to go what what
could stay
and i'm back on the road so i'm happy
about that
and that's the thing is that a lot of
people when when this happened there
were a lot of artists that
shut down and there were a lot of
artists that looked at this moment as
like a great opportunity for
absolute creativity when this all first
happened
which way did you go i shut down you did
every comic we were all texting each
other like
two three months in we're like yo i
thought we would be writing all this
time everyone's like so did i my brain
went dead
every comic where like our brains just
completely shut off we were like
what happened to us did somebody is
there a switch we didn't know about and
then the government flicked it and we're
like
uh culturally cancelled um it's a sort
of i don't want to say provocative but
it's a very
leading title um in 2021 for a podcast
yeah you know i think that's because you
know what it is it's real people having
real conversations in my backyard
and you know i want people to when you
come and do my podcast
we're hanging out we're really just
hanging out and we're smoking cigars
we're drinking some
liquor or whatever it is you're drinking
and and uh if you're into the uh
devil's lettuce you can smoke that
that's not my thing but
feel free and and uh it's really just
you're being a fly on the wall when i'm
hanging out with people
yeah you're literally getting to hear
how we actually talk and that's why i
call it culturally counsel because
a lot of times when we're hanging out
and we're like could you imagine if
somebody heard this conversation
they would think we were awful human
beings and i often say that in my act
now that if i was to read a transcript
of everything that i just said on stage
and you didn't tell me it was me who
said it i would cancel myself
right yes this is though how much of
this is is
you when you were younger before you hit
you'd sit around with your friends and
have these wildly funny conversations
and you had to have thought
god why can't we just monetize this why
can't this
just be the thing this is entertaining
people would listen to this this has to
that dream you had
all those years ago coming true today we
see the thing is years ago we relied on
everybody else we
we've become an industry that has become
self-sufficient on our own
for a lot a lot of us can just survive
on our own wits now
like you don't need a major network to
sign you up anymore you don't need
a movie deal or or tv deal you can
literally just start something up and
and and make something good out of
absolutely nothing
and uh the idea of real talk a lot of
people say oh it's real talk
we're real but there's something
incredibly authentic about listening to
you and your friends because
did you listen to it by the way i did
yeah yeah and i'll tell you the one
thing that i liked is that
you i listen to a lot of interviews um
but the one thing you don't get from a
lot of reviews that you listen to
is a sense of
history between people right
this is this is this is people the
things you talk about are not the first
time talked about these things
oh yeah that's what's fun about it it's
like you know what it was i i used to
really like
this is some really corny i used to love
tv show friends
and yeah i always found the first three
seasons kind of
but then they started as it got more and
more progressed
the seasons got more and more they
started using inside jokes
from previous episodes and it's kind of
like being around your friends you have
all these inside jokes so
you know i want people to hear that you
know i don't want to
i don't want to have the thing where you
sit and i'm like so how did you get into
this business and what was it like for
you growing i'm like
no that's boring that's that's literally
what we do in every interview we get
so this was our chance to hang out and
show the world that look
yeah these are real guys and you know
them as such and such but
we're we're we're real people having
real conversations
and they may be funny they may not be
funny but they're just literally how a
conversation goes
and the great thing is when you are with
your friends so telling a story whether
it's you know trying out prince's
clothes or being at eddie murphy's house
if you tell that to people who aren't
your friends it sounds like a flex
when you tell it to people who are your
friends they can bust your balls about
which
is sort of a freeing kind of way to tell
that story right yeah
it's it's because you want to brag about
it like you don't want to brag
what i'm saying is you want to talk
about some of the things you've got in
your life and things you've done
but even when i tell my friends like all
right you dropped something you just
dropped you know like all right never
mind i keep the stories to myself
because i'm like
i'm not telling you to brag i'm telling
because i'm just as excited about this
as you should be
so when you when you're with other like
people like-minded people and you're
telling these stories
they may have something to add to it
themselves
and have you put have you how far ahead
have you thought of your sort of
you know dream list of people that you
that you would like to have on
people that you know you hit with well i
don't know yet to be honest i keep
getting asked by my producers like who
are my next who are you going to have
next and
i'm like i make these calls to my
friends i'm like that guy wants to do it
this one wants to do it
and then i like to pair people together
i don't like to do just say you and me
i would do me raw's and then somebody
who would be like a wild card to this
you know what i mean somebody who'd be
like what
you know like when i had um rick fox on
with the comedian joey medina
and then i had michael jai white on she
was i wanted to have
one of my jiu jitsu teachers high
machado on but his english isn't that
great
and he's not that good of a talker so i
brought michael jai white on who's a
great martial artist
and can talk as well and hegan will be
like oh i know mike i know you were
his guard comes down and it gets more
relaxed but really it's about being
comfortable i want everybody to be
comfortable i don't want them to feel
any pressure in that situation
uh so much has been happened in the in
in comedy over the last couple of years
whether it's comics having to apologize
for jokes
they had done years ago um what is your
take on this world right now listen
first of all have you ever met somebody
who's um
that soft i've never actually physically
met one
no they exist on the internet
but is the internet real like these real
people are these bots
are we being played and then i notice
when i go to meetings with like networks
or studios or whatever they're
all so overly pc i've
this isn't coming from the outside this
is coming from the inside
this isn't average people saying we
can't say this you can't do that
it's the people on the inside dictating
this and it's frustrating to me because
i'm like
you're creating a situation that's going
to be very difficult to get out of
and it's dangerous because you're
stopping people the thing is when people
are saying
you need to be tolerant and i'm like i
get that i am
first of all i'm very tolerant so it
doesn't make sense to me to begin with
but we'd be like you need to be tolerant
and if you're not taller we're going to
cancel
i'm like wait that's not tolerance
that's the exact opposite of tolerance
uh you uh you taught a lot of people
you know with with your stand-up what it
was like to grow up in a brown household
and you were the first example from that
a lot of people had in their lives of
what that sort of
the look through that window window was
like um
it's a difficult thing to do now it
seems to you know even discuss what may
be perceived
as stereotypes even if it is your own
family
and you want to make a joke it's a it
seems like it's a real tough world right
now for that
it's you know what it is it's not a
tough world is that people's if your
intention is pure
and you're telling your story it's funny
because somebody somebody has messaged
me on instagram like complaining about
something i said eight years ago
you're part of the problem you're doing
you're sexualizing
this and you're part of the and i'm like
what this i go
i didn't reply to them but i'm like
you're mad at a story i told but that
story really happened to me
so shouldn't i be mad that that happened
to me not you mad for like it's just
we're going backwards and we're not
progressing as
as a race as a human race we're not
we're not all moving together anymore
we're backing up
and we're separating we're segregating
ourselves again which is the wrong
direction
because growing up it was all about i i
learned
all these things about different
cultures because we all hung out with
each other we all broke each other's
balls we all learned about each other
this way
but if everybody's gonna be so scared
they're gonna go into a box
and stay in that box because that's
their safe place you can't be that safe
your whole life
you need to take chances and if you're
not going to take chances
bubble wrap yourself and stay in the
house do you feel that you're sort of
alone sometimes
being an individual who has friends that
you may not agree with everything with
oh no i mean i think everybody has
friends listen i have friends
and i have extreme friends and when i
when i say
like i have uh one friend who wears like
these pro
trump shirts around me and he's like a
gangster so i can't say anything to him
about it
and it's like he's like we'd be like
trump's the best f the rest
democrats and and and rats is written in
all caps so it's demo
rats you know what i mean i'm like oh
boy and then i got my friends that come
to my house like d.l hughley and these
guys they're like
you know this trump that i'm like oh my
god and i don't care either way i'm like
enough with all this nonsense can we
just get back to just being people again
we don't need teams can i be on team
human brother i could not agree with you
more when did you do your first netflix
special and did you do the first netflix
special
i did the one i kicked it off that was
in 2013
it aired and look at that world now
i mean it's this is the platform oh i
know it's completely different world
we're living and you know when i
when i joined with them their whole
thing was were you know the small
company and we don't want to be like the
big guys and
we're not going to dictate i'm like oh
yeah now they don't even call me back
do you feel that uh do you still get
people do you like because
do you sort of are you are you at all
pissy that you don't get the recognition
that heavily that you were the first you
were the guy
you know there there was a moment in my
life where i was very sensitive about
that stuff like
i want to be recognized i i and then i
realized
i was getting mad at things that i
didn't wasn't getting as opposed to
appreciating all the things i had
already gotten and and i think i think
if i learned one
thing in this past year it's about
appreciation and
recognizing when to shut up
right um and uh as a dad how old's the
boy now
my boy will be two in like uh 10
in 11 days and how's that been
i mean we're going through some stuff
right now
you know custody stuff so but um when i
see him it's great i mean he's amazing
and he's very like when he's with me he
won't go to anybody
yeah like he as soon as he sees me he's
like clings on to me he's like doesn't
let go and i'm like it's the best
feeling in the world and the worst
feeling in the world because you're like
it's the best thing to know your son
even though he's been away from you so
much recognizes you and like that's my
dad
that's who i love that's who i want to
be with and then it sucks when he's
leaving because he can tell he's sad
that he has to leave
yeah are you the kind of are you the
kind of dad where you're almost like
it doesn't matter what you're into i
don't care but the one thing you will
have is a sense of humor
do you feel that way he's already got a
sense of humor
does he oh my god and it's frustrating
because
he doesn't dick sometimes you know like
like i'll be i'll put his food i'll put
him in the high chin i'll put the food
there
and then i'm like and then when he's
done he just starts throwing the food
and i'm like hey
stop that and then he'll literally like
take
like say this was this food and be like
and then like
like slowly hold it over the over the
thing i'm like don't
don't and then he'll look right at me
like and let go
and i'm like you son of your mother this
is
and then when you look at me i'm like
and i'm like
but then i'm like that's what i would
have done yes it is
you